America First non fatal we want to build
a much better believable people and we
must do it nonfatal communication very
much hire America first to lead by an
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders more
of insiders fighting for insiders time
to stop insiders fighting for Insiders
America First Love the
flow
69 now it's time for new believable
people and we must do it if we don't
control insiders this will be over and
over to lead fight and any big fat love
find common ground to hold the spread of
lives and we must do it big fat love
find common ground ground to hold the
spread of lives
and America First America First non
fatal we want to build a much better
believable people and we must do it
nonfatal communication very much hire
America first to lead by and any
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders more
stop insiders fighting for insiders
America First Love the
[Applause]
[Music]
flow
I woke up in my
head I woke
up I woke up in my head
this I woke
up the not I know demo gorg's
not Demo's
[Music]
not justone in thees
makeone in
theone thees
makeone
the find him call me back like there's
something wrong find him call
name find him call me back like there's
something wrong find him someone's in
the
[Music]
Des the Demo's not I know what good the
Demo's not
the's
not in thees
makeone in
theone in the doesn't make them just
someone's in
the him call me back like there's
something wrong find him call
name find him call me back like there's
something wrong find him someone's in
the
[Music]
D no no
no just me feel like
I'll no no no
like a
[Music]
bab
something you know back when I was in
the academy we would follow every toast
with a
[Music]
song
ch
[Music]
hey fancy seeing you here glad to uh be
with you I know this is not a normal
show we kind of just decided to to drop
this um let me sort of set the stage
here uh # clean slate
is something that we've talked about
it's something that I'd mentioned before
we went on Christmas break and it's
something that's been kind of heavy on
my heart from a really from your
feedback from a lot of people actually
and then it was reinforced spending time
with human beings in real life over
Christmas and New Year's um and I'll get
to the schedule in a second you know the
show is is coming back on the 22nd The
Daily Show and next week uh Monday with
have a black and white and the gray
issues and an apologetics episode with
Alex Jones a lot of stuff happening here
in the next week but um that's not
really what I want to talk about right
now clean slate is an initiative that
we're starting
here and I ask that you consider joining
us let's start with this what are we
doing what are we
doing I mean what is everyone
doing with our lives here and how we use
these tools you're watching this
probably on one of the platforms
hopefully rumble or mug Club Maybe
YouTube but you may at one point you
would see a clip on Instagram and by God
hopefully that 10 seconds gets into that
timeline along with chicks dancing and
yoga pants selling you products that
they don't use uh to develop a body you
won't have and live a lifestyle that
you'll never
live and we're feeding this machine all
this is the feedback that I get from so
many of you is you feel like you're in a
rat race you feel like a hamster on a
wheel
um and it used to be once upon a time
this is kind of the fundamental change I
think that's taking place in this
country and really across the
world people used to create content or
people used to use social media uh used
to create the content and hopefully
reach the people who they felt it served
it was relevant to
them now we live in a world where that's
not the business as a matter of fact
you're discouraged from that and you're
just discouraged as a consumer from
using these platforms that way we now
have people who aggregate content that
they didn't make to try and reach an
audience they don't care about through
feeding a machine which we call an
algorithm and all that means is it's an
artificial brain it's not even
human and it determines what you
see and what you
consume this is why you feel like you're
stuck in a in a rat race it's an entire
industry of appealing to an artificial
brain that doesn't even
exist let me let me just kind of break
this down for you too and something to
think about social media is a term that
people use and I want to get into how
this is a tool right tools are meant to
serve you that's not where we are right
now and I'll just let you know right off
the bat here Clean Slate if you go to my
Instagram or my Twitter right now
everything is
gone I've wiped everything little secret
lot of journalists do this at New York
Times at Washington Post because they
want to evade accountability we're doing
this that hopefully you can follow suit
and we will move forward using these
platforms as the tools that were
designed to serve us not us not you
serving them let me ask you about social
media
social when you're on social Med when
you're scrolling through Tik Tok when
you're scrolling through Instagram when
you're looking at nothing but YouTube
shorts do you feel particularly
social let me ask you this do you often
find yourself using social media when
you're in a
room with the people you love who love
you you you ever leave Instagram or Tik
Tok any of these places after an hour
and feel better for having done
it it's a genuine question and it's
something that I hear from from everyone
about on a regular basis let me kind of
give you an
analogy because this happened to me
uh social media these platforms this
device that is constantly bombarding you
and by the way collecting your
information it's like being at a party
you be at a you ever been at a party and
there's someone there and you have a
bunch of your friends your family and
there's someone who doesn't quite pick
up on the social cues and they won't let
you go and you want to end the
conversation but you can't because you
want to spend time with the people
around you who you've come to see that's
the device and your hand you don't
really want to be attached to
it but it won't let you go only it's a
machine it's a machine that doesn't care
about you and this is the thing working
in the industry I know a lot of you use
it to stay in touch with families and
great and these are tools that I
absolutely believe are pivotal that you
can use going into an election I just
don't believe that that's where we are
right now and there needs to be a change
of course before we get to the point
that there's no turning back we have to
get out of these social media ghettos
and the Reliance on them well we'll hear
this in the industry side um you just
you got to be there you need more you
need more reals you need more Clips you
got you have to do it you have to do it
you have to do it if you want to remain
relevant if you want to remain
competitive competitive for
what competitive for what for 10-second
views in a timeline where people don't
even remember where it came from or what
they learned or what it
meant it's very different you they used
to say that TV was going to rot your
brain and just to be clear this show
22nd Daily Show I want you want to know
watch the show this show is a time
capsule something happens to me I would
say show show my kids who their father
was show them the show but it's a
program that's designed for you and a
lot of the things that we discuss for
example Gerald doing an apologetics
episode with Alex Jones that'll be going
up next week the algorithm the
artificial machine would tell you you
don't want to see it I don't
agree you let me know you let the AI
know if you want to see it do you
realize that if I listen to these
consultants if I listen to these these
firms that exist now to tell you exactly
how to profit off of new media content
to be clear there's a business and the
model is create nothing because it costs
money it costs resources to create
something but profit off of everything
clip someone else's stuff and distribute
it and hopefully you appeal to the
algorithm but let me explain to you the
difference between doing a full length
program or for example using these
social media
platforms as tools you know when I was a
kid and they would say TV would rot your
brain as an example but it was different
if you went to a live show you bought a
ticket you were there you were sharing
an experience with people I can remember
as a kid my dad would usually tape it uh
because it's past my bedtime staying up
with him the next day after watching
David Letterman or if there was
something really funny on Saturday Night
Live or he would show me these films
that he grew up with we we would sit
around and watch it together and then
turn it off and usually talk about what
it was that we watched and we felt
better usually watching something
together it actually did help build
community and conversation same thing if
you radio you turn it
on DVD VHS Blu-ray whichever one maybe
you're a betamax guy I don't
know you'd pop it in you'd watch
something you'd move
on same thing even when you YouTube
started out you subscribed to somebody
you saw the
content and then you could discuss it
that's not what happens now who you
subscribe to and what you say you want
to
watch is largely irrelevant because of
an artificial brain telling you what it
is that you need to see the difference
between you controlling the devices
between you turning things on that you
want to watch and using it to actually
help build your community is very
different from a device that is
bombarding you non-stop with a default a
default setting of notifications and a
bang bang Bing while it reads your face
your thumb print and your preferences so
that they can sell you to think about
this for a second when I say sell you
this isn't just some cynical thing again
why do you feel so unhappy so many we
have we have a mental health ISS crisis
I guess we should say that we've never
had in this country and we have more
access to information than ever before
you really should be able to become more
educated now for no money but certainly
less than at any point in history you
should be able to be connected to people
your family your friends more than ever
before because you don't need to pay the
money for a long distance call or get on
a plane right this was supposed to
create accessibility but people are more
isolated than
ever why do you feel that way let me
tell you why let's say YouTube Instagram
Twitter
what's their
Capital eyeballs ears you how do they
make money sponsors ads they're selling
you to the highest bidder when you get a
ding and a ding and a ding and a ding
and a ding and read your face and
thumbprint scan what's your preference
you are the product they are selling
you're just a means to an end for them
to make money and I say this as a free
enterpriser that's why you feel
miserable this is not about serving you
this is not a tool like a radio like a
television like a
hammer you are a tool to
them they don't serve you you are
serving them and it's a really scary
thing it's a really scary time in
history when you take that and then you
also extrapolate what we know about
elections what we know about the
lockdowns what we know about covid but
it's really really hard to identify that
when you're so far gone because you've
been convinced that you like something
you didn't even care about because boom
it was a 10-second view it was a
10-second View and all of a sudden
you're down a rabbit hole and hey your
kids are right there your family is
right there there's nothing wrong with
consuming media there's something really
wrong with the biggest corporations that
have ever existed more powerful than
governments building their business
model off of your inability to turn it
off
and then you have the inability to teach
people truth from fiction and then you
have to get into this Rat Race like
we've talked about you feel like a
hamster on a wheel yeah because you got
it I gotta know what's going on I gotta
know what's going hey do me a
favor just try for a couple of days not
doing it and also proactively looking
for news articles staying in the know do
you really need to be in these social
media ghettos where four companies three
really control all of the information
out there and doesn't make your life
better doesn't make any of you
happier so that's why we're starting the
Clean Slate initiative uh and uh if you
actually go to louth cr.com
cleanslate uh there are the instructions
there if you want to take part and I
want to be clear about what it
is that you do um and an option b
because I understand that this is pretty
severe we've gone through I guess a
digital suicide machine as it were I
considered a rebirth we're not deleting
these platforms but especially as we go
into an election season we're hitting
the reset saying
okay what kind of a legacy do we want to
leave and what kind of a change do we
want to impact and any of you out there
want to have the AI brain determine what
it is that you consume and who you are
based on things that you were posting in
maybe 2009 when the platform was
entirely different from what it is
now we're not saying delete everything
we're saying delete the content so that
you can start fresh and if enough of you
do this it'll throw their algorithms for
a loop and you can just start with a
clean slate it's rare that you get to do
that it's a bigger risk here right now
for us because we know that we're this
is a media
company and it's gone on Twitter
Instagram Facebook at some point that
takes a little bit longer so if you go
to lit.com
cleanslate if this sounds like you and
you were thinking I need a change um I'm
getting sucked in maybe and by the way
there are resources for this too maybe
you're addicted
this happens with a lot of people they
just cannot get off of it even if they
want to this is a
step you can clear your
timelines and put up one post whatever
post it is that you want to put up so
that when people go to your profiles
this is what they see this is what
defines you and include the hashtag
Clean Slate so that hopefully other
people do
it that's what it is now if you if you
don't want to do that and there are ways
to Archive by the way everything you've
done in the past so you don't lose it
yourself personally uh then I would just
ask that you be mindful As you move
forward and use these platforms as tools
to serve you as opposed to chasing the
dragon and serving a master because you
need to understand that that Master is
an artificial brain that doesn't exist
and does not care about you or your
children it would be like a hammer with
sentient it's a terrifying thought guess
what that hammer would be more scared of
Instagram and Tik Tok that's the world
that we're living in So Clean Slate wipe
it if you feel like this is something
you've been wanting to do I can't tell
you how many comments we get especially
people who are concerned with politics
saying I want to have an impact but my
God I just it's just stressful and I
just I then then they have to I have to
go off the grid here's a way to do it
start now moving forward today it's
January what is the date today
January 11th clean slate and you start
you start dominating these platforms out
there so that they fall in line in
service to you you're not just something
they sell to someone who doesn't know
you and doesn't care about you that's
what clean slate is whether you choose
to wipe everything one post hash Clean
Slate or you can include hashtag clean
slate in your timelines as they exist
and as you move forward decide that
you're going to take control of this
and outside of that yep just so you know
not only is the show coming back on the
22nd uh we never really take breaks
we've been working on we've had the
undercover unit here um but pissing off
the most powerful people in the world if
you thought the Nashville Manifesto was
something that is Child's Play compared
to this we have to aim once and aim
right they're out there working on it
right now so we'll have a lot of those
coming up uh when the show comes back
daily on the 22nd but we'll also have
Monday another black and white and the
gray issues uh where I sat down with two
two black women and just talked about
for about an hour and a half Wednesday
Gerald and Alex Jones they did an
apologetics episode and we actually have
a special Nick depalo 30 minute uh
standup special as the OG on Friday and
then uh we're going to have once we get
the final go-ahead here from legal on
the undercover stories that um you know
hey none of this would make sense
business-wise change my mind absolutely
not that's costly doesn't appeal to you
yeah black and white what you're just
going to white guy you're just going to
go into barber shop and talk with people
does not make sense Alex Jones and
Gerald Morgan doing an episode on
apologetics for an hour plus wouldn't
make sense you guys let us know the
undercover unit does not make sense if
you're just trying to appeal to that
algorithm click click click click you're
better off posting an old Andrew Dice
Clay hilarious standup clip and not
giving credit but we want to provide
this to you and you not some artificial
learning machine that seems to get
Dumber or more evil by the day will
determine what it is that we do and I
just ask that you consider not allowing
it to determine what you do going
forward this is not an answer to
everything I get that but it's been
heavy on my heart and
hopefully it is a helpful First Step
hash Clean Slate go to lit.com
cleanslate for the tools available to
you uh if you want to do so I'm going to
see you very soon here on this channel
really looking forward to it this is my
home I love being here and uh here's a
little bit of a taste of what we've been
up to and what's coming up next week
thank
you Mud Club cannot be bought sold or
bargained with that's the reputation the
people who want to silence you who want
to dictate what you hear well guess what
they can't deplatform us all a
full-fledged Network and the
announcements we're about to make mug
Club is bigger than them you mug Club
are the reason that they are scared and
they should
be cuz wait to see what's
next how is it racis well it's not just
black people who are on welfare would
you say sex trafficking M
okay this you're going to have to give
what
yes now in every industry there's often
a person who people think is the man and
then behind the scenes there's there's
the
in the world of standup comedy for
decades that guy is Nick theala oh we
have a video tape of trump saying he
likes to grab but Hillary
doesn't been awesome and we're going to
Alex's home Alex thanks for joining me
again good to be here yeah there's no
subject more important than our Eternal
Souls the fact that we are Eternal
beings made by
God Dre
here I feel like I was they don't around
and they're never going to take your p
no one's going to
[Music]
see you essentially threatening that you
are going to publish this in any event
and I am telling you that if you do that
you do it and you're powerful what we do
going forward including script series
other undercover projects that we are
working on none of it happens without
you hold on to your
butts